at book tv.org I get everyone's
attention my name's Pete Becky I'm the
director of the FA Hyack program here at
George Mason University today we're
really thrilled we have Deirdre
McCloskey here in conversation with my
good colleague Don Boudreau Deirdre has
just come out with the third volume of
her trilogy and the bushwa equality
which builds on the bourgeois virtues
and the bushwa dignity Don will talk
about this in his introduction but I
want to personally congratulate Deirdre
on this collection I think it's the most
ambitious work in economics done during
my career at least in economics and just
an amazing achievement for what you've
done and and generate the conversation
and economics and hopefully we'll have a
great conversation today and time let's
turn it over to you thanks Pete when
Claire Morgan asked me if I would lead
conduct the conversation with Deirdre I
immediately jumped at the at the
opportunity not only is an honor but
there are a few books that one reads in
a scholarly life that fundamentally
change or the deeply change the way you
look at the world and these books have
done that for me and so I'm honored to
be here with with Deirdre Deirdre
McCloskey is taught at the University of
Illinois Chicago from 2000 to 2015 she's
now emeritus
I I would list all the departments in
which she taught but that would take us
through the whole hour
one of them was economics before that
Deirdre taught at the University of Iowa
and also at the University of Chicago
she's been a longtime friend of the
economics department here at George
Mason and of the Mercatus Center I
believe you have your scholarly articles
number about four four hundred
I don't dare put a number on the on the
number of other popular blog post and
and and and magazine articles that
you've written this I also believe he's
our 17th yeah
authored authored book as peek notice
the noted it's the final book in a
remarkable trilogy which will consume
the bulk of our time today but before we
get to the actual conversation let me
quote from Deidre's website which I
encourage you to visit by there's a
great website and has access to most of
the ADRA's works on her website she
protests that she is not a conservative
economists I'm so here is what she is if
you don't mind me putting your words in
your mouth in deuter's word she is quote
a literary quantitative postmodern
free-market progressive Episcopalian
Midwestern woman from Boston who was
once a man not conservative I am
Christian I am a Christian libertarian
and indeed end quote indeed she is were
I to list all of Deidre's achievements I
would again this would be a monologue by
Dawn and not a conversation with Deirdre
so let's let's get let's get to it so
congratulations on the publication of
the third volume I remember being in the
the Mercatus sponsored transcript all
right seminar and that's when I I read
it I haven't yet I just got my I haven't
yet gotten through the entire changed a
lot okay well I remember the trance the
the transcript what tell us for those
who haven't read what are boudoir
virtues and where did this trilogy come
from what's the germ
this trilogy well the the the in the
germ was the the notion of the virtues
by social class they are a stalker see
the peasantry and then I thought gee the
bushwa virtues but all they are are the
virtues as understood in the West in the
east and south and the north of human
society in a commercial context so
courage would be entrepreneurship love
would be solidarity or or personal
consideration and in a business for
example so there's anything specifically
bushwa about the virtues I'm simply
taking the tradition of virtue ethics
so-called which was a long time way that
people in the West talked about being
good and saying well you can be good and
be in an economy too now that comes as
news to a lot of intellectuals and
that's why I wrote the books is to yes
he is to bring the good news to our
wonderful friends on the left and some
on the right who regard a market society
as a well as an abomination as as
corrupting let me be presumptuous and
summarize real quickly what I take to be
the main theme of these three volumes he
knows what I do better than I do so I'm
looking forward to this this is a very
short summary of complex complex ideas
economists since certainly since the
time of Adam Smith have asked what
causes material progress because the
nature and causes of the wealth of
nations there's certainly no question
that there's been a major increase in
the rate of material progress since the
time of Adam Smith a factor of 30 a
factor of 30 you call it the great
enrichment you call it rightly I believe
call it one of the greatest events in
human history probably right after the
invention of agriculture yep and you
found a find every other explanation
that economists have offered for the
great enrichment to be wanting yeah and
your explanation for the great
enrichment is that ideas change yeah in
particularly specifically ideas change
in such a way that practitioners of
bourgeois virtues people who act yeah as
booze wah the burners innovators they
for the first time in history starting
about two hundred twenty fifty years ago
in the northwestern part of Europe
became dignified in the eyes of most
people not everyone but he nights that
most people that unleashed that's right
this creative energy so that's the key
it's not so much that psychology changed
that's what Max Max Weber said claimed
100 years ago and I don't think that's
very plausible it's not that people got
I don't know better it's that this
surrounding society changed its
valuation of what they did so the word
innovation for example was a scare word
until the 19th century
to innovate was to change religious
beliefs or to disturb the social
hierarchy we don't have we don't want
any of that innovation so that's the
main thing that changed in fact I in the
last month or so I've decided that I
this last volume should have been
entitled not I should have had one more
word it's got a long title anyway it's
called bushwa equality how now here's
how I should have said it and this will
shock you
how liberal ideas not capital or
institutions enrich the world because
it's the basic liberal idea not on the
modern American sense but in its older
sense that that people are equal before
the law and equal in social standing
it's that equality that inspired people
and I get more and more evidence of this
every day I'm rereading now an extremely
good biography of the great Norwegian
national hero fridge of nonsan after
whom I'm named and all through it you're
seeing these poor Swedes and Norwegians
inventing stuff in the 19th century you
know the the Primus stove for example
which made Arctic exploration so much
easier because they're being allowed to
Matt Ridley has a nice review of
wonderful region whose raw equality but
he last Sunday in the anandamaya but he
pushes back a little bit yeah he wonders
and I wonder how you'd respond to this
question he asks how do you know the
causal direction and it is true we you
document that the change in rhetoric
occurred starting about 250 years ago
butoh activities came to be more
respected and spoken of with well with
greater dignity Matt wonders was that
the cause was that was that ineffective
well the mother change it's it's it's
it's clear that there's a kind of
backwash mean that the idea of equality
not what I call French equality which
was the idea that equality of result
equality of income which is what we
usually think of but what when I call
Scottish equality namely equality of
human dignity
this is socially and before the law
those
those of course were raised in prestige
by the success of this formula you see
it in Scotland itself for example in
England and Holland to begin with it all
begins and in Holland then the United
States and Australia and so forth and
then in Scandinavian elsewhere and you
see this great success of course that
then increases the prestige of
market-tested
as they call it but I would say to
Ridley that you have to look at the
timing and the comparisons but let's
look at the timing the increase in the
status of economic behavior and bushwa
activity and innovation happens before
any substantial economic success well
before it's around 1700 well actually as
I said it starts in Holland so a hundred
years before around 1600 you have this
flowering of Dutch commercial society
not about a hundred years later the
English adopt a Dutch King a Dutch
central bank a Dutch exchange a Dutch
unfortunately a Dutch national debt I
I'm surprised they didn't adopt the
Dutch language it became so very Dutch
by 1700 and that's way before there was
any substantial payoff so so so the real
payoff comes not so much in the classic
industrial revolution of the late 18th
century but in as you said what I call
the great enrichment of the 19th and
20th century when innovation betterment
just goes completely whacko and as as
Ridley himself says ideas start having
sex and then the baby ideas and the
grand baby ideas have sex and and you
get all this amazing innovation of
mechanical inventions which we can see
all around us but also certain
organization on social inventions
do you have any idea why the idea has
changed yes and that's what I devote
much of this third volume to because as
you said I had shown to my satisfaction
in the second volume that the standard
economic arguments coal is a big
favorite which Matt Ridley favors me he
does and he's wrong you know he's very
nice and very smart but even very smart
people or sometimes wrong and or foreign
trade or the slave trade or exploitation
of the poor or something like that all
those don't work they they don't have
enough oomph from an economic point of
view if you if you think carefully the
economics involved they're just not big
enough to explain a factor of 30 which
is what we're trying to explain and then
historically speaking they don't make
any sense because often well the the
Chinese were exploiting coal for 3,000
years without an industrial revolution
but in the in the third volume I say
okay why why did why do this this
liberal idea becomes so powerful all of
a sudden then it was all of a sudden and
I have I'm sorry to say I haven't got
any snappy answer here's the here's the
here's the simple answer it is that it
was accidents
it was accidents of the politics and
sociology of Europe starting in in 1517
that famous year up to up to 1789 in
that period hierarchy began to break
down
now hierarchy is what runs an
agricultural civilization not
hunter-gatherers but agriculturalists
have these horrible hierarchies you know
i am the lord of the manor and too bad
for you you've got to give me rent sue
texas
and that started to break down and
ordinary people were made bold as a
clear example of this rather late in the
process our English Quakers in which
even women were allowed to speak at the
meeting in which there weren't the in
which there was no hierarchy at all
there was no priest there there there
was no person even appointed by the
congregation and I say that it's not so
much the doctrine of salvation as again
Max Weber said that changed but church
governance that made people bold and I
and I give some evidence for this
there's so there there are accidentally
here's why I say it's what's the point
of calling it accidental I don't want
people to believe that there's something
peculiarly and deeply European about all
this it could have happened in China
with sufficient time it could have
happened in Mayan Guatemala it could
have happened in lots of places maybe a
little later why it didn't happen in
China earlier as a puzzle well that is
this great enrichment but it's it's not
some European this is rather obvious
from the successes of liberal economic
policies with constraints in China and
India right now I think without those
two recent examples would have been much
harder to make this argument we were
talking just before we started filming
about about a book that you and I and
most economists good economists love
Adam Smith's Wealth of Nations
the Blessed Adam Adam right and and Adam
Smith of course famously at least among
people who know his work didn't say very
many favorable things about business
people know I didn't at least on the
surface that's a little bit in tension
with your thesis yeah but but he for one
thing he didn't think much of
entrepreneurship Pete here has spoken of
Smith and Schumpeter and stupidity as
the three forces that we need to be
concerned with and Smith is about
efficiency and Schumpeter is about
innovation about the real cause of
modern economic growth and stupidity
well that's about the government from
the Mossberg and so this myth is not a
it will express it this way Smith didn't
know what his radically egalitarian
ideas about equality before the law and
social equality was going to do he
didn't quite realize that he was
creating a document that would sustain
this move of egalitarianism so you know
he was one of the he was a Smith he's a
great economist but no one saw it coming
let me try this one yeah for the Smith
thing so when Smith does talk about
businesspeople is almost always in the
context of businesspeople to put it in
modern terms lobbying the state
privileges that's what he said he said
the he people think it's not napoleon
according to phrase but it's it's adam
smith who said and spoke of britain as a
nation of shopkeepers and he said these
this commercial system as he called it
which we still have
mercantilism and protectionism
and so on law licensing of occupations
and all the horrible features that have
hung over from the Middle Ages he said
this is a system not appropriate to a
nation of shopkeepers but appropriate to
a nation whose government is influenced
by shopkeepers and that's exactly right
and it's still true one of the
remarkable things about the you do it in
all certainly the last two volumes you
just give this example endings after
example of the how much better
materially
oh it's astonishing it's why is it that
most people don't recognize it why is it
that most people somehow think it's not
as big a deal as you believed it to be
or that it's doomed most people like
pessimism we were talking about it at
lunch why do people like to say the sky
is falling they always do Bob Gordon of
go friend of mine has just written a
book the sky is falling the sky is
falling well Bob maybe I don't think so
it hasn't fallen yet I'm looking around
I don't see pieces of it and and so
there's a deep
I mean people feel that they're
sophisticated if they if they're if
they're pessimists and and it's very
easy to forget or to romanticize one's
youth my my mother is 93 and is a very
intelligent and sharp person in every
way and I'm always saying to her well
mom she says Oh things are talbert's
things are terrible I say but they were
worse than you were when you were a kid
she was born in 1922 she said oh no we
were happy then well her her mother
would put in the Great Depression would
put pieces of cardboard in her shoes so
they wouldn't so the holes wouldn't leak
you yourself Donna have done excellent
service in showing how much cheaper so
many things are
a refrigerator a color TV psychotropic
drugs all kinds of things not not psyche
well yeah not those kind of drugs but
things like like lithium and so forth
which which the richest people in the
world didn't have to fight their mental
illness in 1950 we now have but I don't
know how to get people out of this
dismal mode well it's in addition to nor
do I I'm pessimistic about that in in in
addition to the the interminable
pessimism today I mean not today today
but in the past several years has seen a
return of inequality as yeah yeah
featuring thomas piketty's book of yes
not 2014 which you reviewed brilliantly
and in her also favorable reviewing the
Financial Times yeah of your book Diane
Diane Coyle yeah she talks about it she
talks about and she wonders if you're a
bit too complacent about the future
because of the current concern about
inequality well you know we thought for
a while that we had taken socialism out
to the out to the crossroads by the by
the light of the full moon and pounded a
wooden stake through its heart and it
was dead but socialism since its
invention in the 19th century one of the
great intellectual inventions of the
19th century along with nationalism and
if you like those to try national
socialism is perennial e popular i I
think it is babak's who is here has
pointed out the size of government has
just kept going up and so we keep
thinking that we will help the poor
instead of letting the poor help
themselves so we so I I don't I I think
people like equality and socialism and
so on because they grow up in families
and families are
socialist enterprises mom is the central
planner and so forth but in fact think
of it from an ethical point of view
equality is not the problem there
there's a line in one of a couple of
lines in one of Shakespeare's sonnets I
can't quote it I'm afraid
where he he points this out he says look
I would like to have this man's
handsomeness and this man's intelligence
and this man's strength and it's it's a
it's a hopeless project for us to be
equal but it's not a hopeless project
for us to be rich to enrich the poor
should be our power our purpose and that
I think is an honorable and liberal and
sensible and achievable purpose for well
public policy if you want to talk about
it that way so if not equality if this
change in rhetoric and changing the way
people viewed those who pursue whoosh
whap pursuits yeah if that was
sufficient to bring about this enormous
and wonderful great enrichment I presume
it's the case that if this rhetoric
moves back in the other direction yeah
then we can be doomed yes and I think
you see this in the in the sluggishness
of the economy of Europe the Treaty of
Rome was a wonderful document and broke
down trade barriers among European
nations all to the good and then in
Brussels they thought well you know we
we have to go wee-wee in here again with
a sequin this kind of idea of equality
we've got to eat we've got a what's the
phrase we've got to make the playing
field level playing yeah we got to level
the playing field and so look Cadbury
Cadbury's milk chocolate is not really
chocolate said the
bureaucrats in Brussels it hasn't got
enough cocoa in it so we're gonna
declare a Cadbury's chocolate not
chocolate and you can imagine how this
played in Britain or we're going to take
non-pasteurized Italian cheese and we're
gonna outlaw it because after all the
other stuffs pasteurized that our good
Danish cheese is pasteurized what's
wrong with these Italians and it just
means it's a in its I haven't ever
thought of this before
it's this equality idea that the purpose
of a modern society is to make everyone
equal and it's a crazy program and and a
pointless one if we achieve what John
Rawls argued was the raising of the
bottom that's what we should be doing
the improvements of the worst of and
that's not be done but done by whining
about how many yachts Lillian baked
encore the heir to the Loreal fortune
has that's what Oh Kenny Justin hates
Lily on baked on car and I agree that
she's a jerk she here here she here's an
interesting fact about her if she's
still alive and I know she is
but her Charitable Foundation has
invested in it one half of one percent
of her wealth one half of one percent
compared and 100 percent yachts are
expensive
yeah yachts are expensive and so she
hasn't much yet but that doesn't make
people poor what makes people poor is a
lack of equality equality of before the
law take take take the drug laws for
example which we're now you know I've
known this for many years most of the
people here have but suddenly the
American public is realizing that the
drug laws are not equally enforced
shocked and an equality of social
standing so we respect each other that's
what makes for a vital entrepreneurial
Society I don't want to slip myself into
suffering the pessimism that I that you
and saw you fight against not that I try
to fight against but and I say the
rhetoric of the past few years now it's
been tearing the intellectual rhetoric
that Thomas Piketty stuff yeah certainly
the political rhetoric now it's terrible
it's as bad as it's worse than it's been
at any point in my lifetime I know is it
possible that we're we're seeing the
beginning of a return to the ages of
hierarchy hears word might not where is
where it might are you still optimistic
I'm so optimistic I'm just an optimist
you can't change gender without being an
optimist but but I I think I think the
demonstration effect is very powerful I
think India embarked on liberalisation
of what what the with the Indians called
the license raj of per capita income
growing at 1% a year per as opposed to 5
to 7 percent per year per capita now in
1991 because they saw the Chinese doing
it and so what we used to call the red
Chinese in 1978 saw Hong Kong doing it
and and so roughly I think the world
will become more liberal in my sense in
the next 50 years and I expect that was
to result in a gigantic worldwide
enrichment for example sub-saharan
Africa in particular I predict a great
future for sub-saharan Africa has more
genetic variability than any other part
of Alma Homo sapiens
and so when they stop miss
governing themselves so unlike we
Europeans ooh-hoo you only had a first
world war in the Second World War in the
Holocaust and communism and fascism we
were so clever by comparison with these
stupid sub no this is all ironic but but
but when the sub-saharan Africans have
equality before the law and dignity and
when they stop having a large government
control their large governments their
large bands of robbers they will grow
and because of the genetic variability
the greatest mathematicians musicians
intellectuals artists scientists will
all have black faces which I think will
be a wonderful irony the racism of
Europeans in East Asians let's step back
I hope you're right
let's step back from the books for a
moment so you were trained as an
economist in the night I was 60s yeah if
she called going to Herbert being
trained isn't it you've done ok for
yourself thank you
what is your assessment of the state of
the economics profession today well
compared to when you began well I don't
think it's improved all that mentioned
and it's in some ways it's worse I mean
economists very surprisingly in the last
50 years and I've been in the profession
about 50 years have become more arrogant
which is almost unbelievable considering
how arrogant they were in the 1960s ever
get in what way well arrogant lots of
ways thinking that they have the
solution that that sociologists and
English professors are stupid that
they're just the cat's meow in every way
intellectually and politically and and
there's no there's no basis for it
I think one of the great problem
in modern economics is the lack of
understanding I'm like Hayek and Keynes
and lots of other earlier economist that
to be a good economist you need to have
a full culture you've got to be a
humanist as well as a quantifier you've
got to have both so I advocate with with
my my friend Bert Bert Bert Wilson of
coined the term human ah mcc's economics
that doesn't lose the mass if you need
it and we often do that thinks
quantitatively when that's appropriate
but then thinks intelligently about
categories and that's what the
humanities do that's what the humanities
are is the study of categories in
theology does God exist is the simple
one exist not exist in in philosophy
what is the mate what is the category
knowledge what is it justified true
belief is that enough that's a
categorical inquiry and most of abstract
mathematics not applied mathematics but
but existence theorems and so on is
categorical talk what categories do
these things fall into and then once
you've got the categories then you can
measure so I think that a a more
civilized economics a in economics that
takes seriously philosophy and
literature is the is the weight of the
future but to answer your question
straightforwardly economists are rushing
in the other direction and like the
perverted proverbial lemmings are aiming
for the cliff I remember on the same
topic really I remember I first met you
in actually April of 1986 so Wow
30 years ago yeah I was 12 well I was
younger I was George Celgene and I late
John blundell jagai Don Lavoie John
winter here in Fairfax and I was struck
by something you said that they had
never heard this from an economist who
had any favorable connection with George
Mason that Karl Marx had a lot to teach
us hearing it and so an interest so
briefly what well what is the coherence
well my my joke is that Karl Marx I say
to my libertarian friends I say Karl
Marx was the greatest social scientists
of the 19th century without compare and
they all get mad at me and then I turned
to my my left-wing friends I was once a
Marxist myself and I say and he was
wrong about almost everything and so
they get mad that's which which is why I
don't have any friends
but what Marx as you could say that the
questions marks as much asked are the
important ones is there a pattern to
history are there stages of history
actually it was Adam Smith was one of
the early stage there's but Marx of
course took it much further is our ideas
independent of material conditions or is
the superstructure a mere consequence of
the of the material base and he asked
all these questions and he got all the
answers wrong but he asked the questions
in a serious way so I really had my
remarks in a lot of ways
I admired I've come to admire other
people too but as a kid I was a Marxist
because I was a socialist I was a Joan
Baez socialist I say I played a guitar
and sang the labor songs I know more
left-wing songs
than most of my left-wing friends and
what's irritating is that there are no
good libertarian songs so get to work
come on say it was barks who coined the
term Industrial Revolution is that go no
it was a the first use of English it
would have been used in French before
the first prominent use of English was a
follower of Marx Arnold Toynbee not his
uncle or his nephew between the
universal history and age 31 which is
when he died he gave lectures on the
Industrial Revolution in England and
there basically the Communist Manifesto
fleshed out and that became what most
people to this day think happened in the
Industrial Revolution and that is the
omission of exactly there was a
brilliant spoof of this by seller and
Yeatman in their great book 1066 and all
that where they said around 1800 all the
richest men in England
all of a sudden realized that women and
children could work twenty-five hours a
day without many of them dying or
becoming excessively deformed this was
known as the Industrial Revolution and
and basically that idea taking taking
novels of the times especially Charles
Dickens as reports on the end of
evolution when he he didn't know
anything about it he spent most of his
life in London which
is not having an industrial revolution
so here's a question that I know
economic historians debate and I wonder
where you come down was there an
industrial revolution other what there
was there what was it slow or was it
fast enough that we can legitimately
call it as we do it by historical
standards here's the history of the
world in one diagram let me see
I'll pretend them I don't know anyway
start here in here earlier times this is
earlier time say the invention of
language or something and it goes along
at two dollars a day two dollars two
dollars three dollars one dollar a day
and then an 1800 goes like this factor
30 factor 30 you can make a case if you
include improvements in quality that's
more like a factor of 100 per capita 100
everyone in this room is the descendants
of unspeakably poor and ignorant people
and here we are so yeah there was an
industrial revolution but but here's the
key point as a number of US economic
historians say there had been other
industrial revolutions the the glory of
Greece and the grandeur wrong song China
you know it happened a lot of times
certain periods in Mesopotamia there had
been industrial revolutions and so
there's there's but what was strange
about this one is that it continued and
it continued and it continued and it
continued to this day and so there has
to be something else not just a few guys
get together and invent I don't know
water wheels but they invent water
wheels and I think well let's see what
can we do with these let's turn them
into airplanes and you know they do all
kinds of other things and that requires
a deep
change in how many people there are who
are allowed as the English say to have a
go that's the key point having a go in a
traditional agricultural society
oh no no goes here you're not allowed
you're not no no not permitted playing
devil's advocate so most economists
would say well we do need something else
but that's something else is better
institutions or a set of better
institutions that doesn't work what it
and I devote a good deal of space in the
last two volumes to this new
institutionalism that my old friend Doug
North who died a few months ago
advocated and lots of other people and
there are lots of problems with it
institutions I it's become world bank
orthodoxy and my scornful description of
us is add institutions and stir you want
a good legal system you want an
english-style legal system provide all
the lawyers with wigs that'll do it
and the problem is that there needs to
be a much deeper ethical change in the
society and ethical change about one's
own behavior to be sure but especially
about other people's behavior
about how you evaluate commercial
honesty and that's a change which it has
to do with institutions but has to do
with the weather - it has do with lots
of things but it's not as if you can
just switch on an institution and see it
work let's take a case that is often
cited the Glorious Revolution of 1688 in
in Britain well
Doug north and his colleagues said aha
now we have good property rights in
Britain after 1688 and it just ain't so
anyone who knows anything about English
legal history and I've studied it a bit
knows that English laws of contracted
property were established in a famous
phrase before the time of Edward the
first there were anti-monopoly acts of
parliament seventy years before the
Glorious Revolution so prop and and then
comparatively China has very good
property laws in the 16th 17th 18th
century and before in fact for hundreds
of years depending on the well for
hundreds of years they had to security
of property in and the emperor didn't
bother them and they and yet they didn't
have the Industrial Revolution so you
know you don't deny that institutions
are important you know better I that
they are the spark that's the key point
as I say I'm an ethic this question well
I say in the title how liberal ideas as
I'd like to say it now not capital or
institutions because cap you gotta have
capital to have a building you gotta
have bricks right you gotta put the
bricks on top of each other and mortar
and so forth so you gotta have capital
but it's a it's the capital is of no use
unless you have the ideas for innovation
beforehand as Keynes said I'm not a big
Keynesian these days I once was the the
reward to capital could be driven down
to zero in a couple of generations if
you just keep making the same stuff over
and over again and don't have any new
ideas of course that's gonna happen
you're gonna run into sharply diminished
returns to capital and and and the same
thing holds for institutions their
intermediate yeah you've got to have
property rights
actually the problem with property
rights is a little sharper because the
problem with property rights is that
what you mean by an organized society is
that it has property rights Genghis Khan
succeeded as the great Mongol leader
because he insisted on the Mongols
obeying property rights he said you
steal a horse or a wife and I'll kill
you
and they said oh ok we'll stop stealing
horses and wives and they became a great
military power so it's it's commonplace
to have property rights but in any case
the these these other so-called causes
are intermediate at best the spark as
you put it is equality equality before
the law and equality of social dignity
and that's new that's new and weird by
1776 the notion that all men and by the
way when women deer are created equal
and are endowed by their creator with
certain inalienable rights among which
are life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness was somewhat of a commonplace
among advanced your European
intellectuals this phrase was written to
last by an owner of slaves but let's
let's pass that but but but it was only
about a hundred years old as a Radek as
a clear political program in this in the
17th century the idea that people were
equal was viewed as extremely radical
and dangerous and my word we've got to
suppress these levelers and and
primitive Communists and Quakers and we
got to stop all this stuff I love the
focus on ideas I have a couple questions
for you let's start with this one why
are economists that's the group I know
best
yeah why are economists so resist or man
but no best why are economists so
resistant to recognizing the roles of
ideas well because there was you do
agree that they all were so absolutely
there I I won't name him because he's
such an excellent scholar but I read a
paper by an economic historian friend of
mine who was talking about the history
of books in Europe anything all through
the paper they put the the word ideas in
scare quotes
they're not real yeah there there was so
there were some influence people claimed
from ideas but okay the the I don't know
if this is a reason yeah I guess it is a
reason from about 1890 to about 1980
which is a nice keeping it in mind most
thinkers intellectuals were materialists
and even people conservative people were
materialists and certainly Marxist work
and they and it's just the it's just the
cynicism of modern intellectual life
Marx and Freud being early examples of
it to the terminal their harmonix of
suspicion as they say to say oh yeah you
claim you're dominated by ideals but I
know it's because you're you have a you
have stock in the General Motors
Corporation that's why you're talking
this way my friend Wayne booth a great
professor of English called it called
this attribution this argument motive
ISM that you're I see you are motivated
by your selfish interests and of course
economists are specialists in this like
journalists they're they're professional
cynics and and they're motivated to
think of material forces price
and incomes and I a I'm an economist I
agree as important and I think they are
too but but then then they tend to say
and that's all we need my colleague the
great economist Gary Gary Becker was an
extreme example of this or George
Stigler another great economist Kalima
and the trouble with this is it's what
the English professors call a
performative contradiction because these
are professors and journalists saying
ideas expressed by professors and
journalists are pointless interest is
all that matters and you can see that
that's there's kind of a you name two of
the most notable University of Chicago
professors yeah there's a third who was
also a calling of yours Milton Friedman
well he was much less than so what was
Freeman's well I have a story as a young
assistant professor at Chicago this must
have been around 1979 I mean 69 or it is
1970 something like that I was standing
I was in the coffee room of the Social
Science Building and Milton Friedman gen
George Stigler
goodbye by the way often played tennis
and Milton was very short and George
zorrito is one of the great comic comic
scenes of academic life to see them
playing tennis on the and the court on
the court did one have an advantage over
the other no no because because Milton
would run very fast
George wouldn't lose and it's very funny
to watch but but but what the years what
their conversation is you know these
great economist and I I admire them both
very much and George said Oh Milton
you're such a preacher you're always
telling people that we should we should
go for free trade and I I believe that
people are against free krei
because it's in their interest to be
against free trade and there's no point
in talking to them and Friedman said
what but George I'm I that's that's that
you said that's the difference between
us I'm a teacher
and I believe that people advocate their
protection and so forth because they're
misled and if I can just get them to
understand this stuff they'll be better
and George was just disdainful of this
your jaw you're crazy you're just a
preacher let me ask you if I made the
comment on another great hero of mine
also an economist who put a lot of
emphasis on ideas economists play some
role in in your in your books if I have
one criticism is that this economist
should have played an even larger role
it's Julian Simon yeah so what what
Julian Simon is you know his is his main
idea yeah was that the ultimate resource
is human creativity he's right and a
human effort the same creativity and
effort that I can't believe unleashed by
booth what dignity that's right and so I
think Julian died young which is a
terrible mistake
destroy the sixties yeah you you mustn't
die young if you're gonna have sustained
intellectual effect unless you're Kurt
girdle or something and I completely
agree with him that this talk of
resources is reinfect I learned it from
him essentially the talk of resources is
kind of silly that they're not resources
look rare-earths weren't rare until we
discovered they could be used for
computer batteries then they became rare
bauxite was useless dirt until we
discovered it could be made and with a
lot of electricity into aluminum so he's
absolutely correct about that and a few
other economists not too many Israel
Kerzner is another example
Israel points out that the
the industrial well let's call it my
name because I'm that's how it should be
because it's so amazing the great
enrichment he said was a free lunch and
more or less had to be because it all it
was was a marginal investment let's see
let's let's put a little more money into
into ships to run the slave trade and
that'll make us rich that wouldn't have
made them rich as it did I mean we got a
production possibility curve just
leaping up he's that way and there are a
few other economists who keep tending to
what because they the Shubert aryan
insight and namely Schumpeter himself
and a few others but mostly economists
learned how to say marginal benefit
equals marginal cost and then they can't
remember to say anything else
and I'm in favor of efficiency I've
always advocated for it but but but it's
not what modern economic growth was it's
not imperfect property rights that then
you fix and then you get economic growth
that's not what did it it's as you said
and as Julian says it's this explosion
of human creativity I like to point out
to my classes you alluded to the
production possibilities curve and of
course that's how we depict economic
growth this yeah expansion out of that
curve and one of the standard ways and
economists say well that the industrial
excuse me that the production
possibilities curve which can shift out
as if we discover more natural resources
and of course that in reality more or
less they're created they're not yes
they're not discovered well but that's
the the Austrian way of talking about it
of that word is correct discovery not
discovery a year well in not well in
in distance I imagine that the the
native inhabitants of Pennsylvania in
the year 1000 and no idea were probably
upset at this bubbly stuff in their
critics okay yeah it wasn't a result of
water yeah yeah so back to the book 1848
plays a prominent role yeah it does and
so what happens in 1848 what happens in
1848 around Europe are revolutions
bushwa revolutions on the whole that
then become often radicalized in in
months I mean sis isn't something that
takes years immediately happens the
great German migration to the United
States in the eighteen eighteen fifties
is to a surprising extent a direct
result of the failures of revolutions in
the in the German lands and and they
more or less all fail in fact the only
large country that doesn't have one in
Europe is is Britain but it has
something close to it I mean it has a
really scary period of the the Irish
Famine and agitation and so forth and
what what it becomes a important
symbolic date because it's when
socialism was truly invented when this
terrible idea of using compulsion
violence to organize the society in
instead of agreement and persuasion
becomes popular and alas it becomes
popular among the formerly liberal
intellectuals the perfect example of
this and I love him in many ways is John
Stuart Mill who is both the most
eloquent and clear clear minded exponent
of liberalism understood as I'm talking
about it and then also one of the first
of the major intellectuals
turn towards socialism so he sees a very
interesting figure and what's remarkable
is that by the 1880s essentially oh the
intellectuals of Europe have turned
against capitalism why I don't know if I
know I'd write a fourth book I I have
some gestures in this but this is partly
such a thick book because I was gonna
write six books I was going to call it a
sexology and sell a lot of books and
then I thought no wait a second that
doesn't satisfy bushwa virtue so I
crammed everything into the last one and
some of my speculation and and indeed
just observation about this the this
amazingly quick change in the middle of
the nineteenth century maybe it's a it's
a fathers and sons thing because almost
without exception the artists
journalists intellectuals who turn
against capitalism are the children the
sons especially the sons who do this of
merchants lawyers owners have been the
most famous example as angles who
actually continued to own a cotton
textile factory while railing against
the very idea of cotton textile
factories so Hayek has a famous essay
calling intellectuals and socialism in
1949 it does and Hayek's thesis there
just to summarize it is that intellect
intellectuals are the the goal betweens
between the you know them
yeah the researchers and the deep
scholars right and the the general
public right and i believe that ideas
matter i do
yeah we're agreed and so when when
intellectuals start changing their ideas
they're changed ideas filter down and
Hayek's thesis to the general public
right they do
if the intellectuals began to change
their ideas 160 years ago then are we
doomed I mean surely then well why is
the great enrichment still occurring
well but return to something we talked
about there's two halves that question
you and I and most of the people in this
room are fighting the good fight trying
to change the way intellectuals look at
believe a saddle group we're a small
group but look we're we're we're smart
and we're hard-working and we're gonna
do it damn it I told you I was an
optimist as to why it continues why the
great enrichment continues again there's
this demonstration effect and there's
this basic uncontrollability I was
thinking as I was driving here and I
mean through from from the airport from
Dulles Airport looking at the at the
richness of Northern Virginia and
thinking to myself this can't be stopped
one of the you know what's her name Gigi
junior senator from Massachusetts
Elizabeth Warren yeah it she's Jesus I'm
sure she's a nice person and by the way
she's an Indian but she she's her people
who think the laws the way to go and
adding more and more and more
regulations they it's very hard to
control an economy like the United
States even with this gigantic size of
government that Bob Higgs is so
eloquently
discussed look I'm gonna make a
confession I've had a lot of work done
in my apartment in Chicago have a loft
bourbon in Chicago it's done by
non-union workers and I haven't ever
gotten a building permit
I hope and admitting this on national TV
doesn't get me into trouble it probably
will I mean that's the way life is but
I've never gotten the building permit
and if you thought that laws were
effective its warned does and that
they're obeyed just all the time then
that would be just a shocking fact but
I'll bet you half the construction in
Chicago of the small-scale construction
the reformed remodeling doesn't have
building permits so you know and doesn't
we don't obey Union monopolies too bad
so mighty might it be that we
intellectuals I'm at I don't want to go
the full direction of stigler's view but
might it be that we intellectuals are
not as influential as we sometimes think
because if intellectual have been
railing against capitalism 460 yeah
that's right that's right
and so very the ideas they keep it going
must be at a more grandma's right that's
what we're level and I think what's
happened is that the the breadth or the
depth I don't know quite how to describe
it of thinking people people with
serious political opinions that I mean
Jim James Buchanan and the upper levels
of this I mean just people is much
bigger than it once was and that there
are many many many people who believe in
trade tested betterment and think boy
gee it's great we have suburbs with
these nice houses and oh boy what a
wonderful country I love America and
even though at the heights of the in
tell agencia whether in the National
Review or the nation they're they're
railing against each other and and the
society in which they live so I have the
sense that there's this momentum to
capitalism
which is very hard to stop now I don't
think it's impossible to stop because
we've you know how do I know it's like
infant baptism do you believe in infant
baptism believe in it I've seen it do
you do you do you believe that economic
growth can be stopped by absurd
excessive regulation over taxation and
Wars and and stupid policies yeah hey I
believe it I've seen it what I mentioned
Bob Higgs is working yeah documents to
my satisfaction that things pretty much
came to a stop in the United
economically yeah in the u.s. in the
1930s because of what Bob calls regime
uncertainty certainly was yeah I
completely agree with Bob's argument
which doesn't make me popular with a lot
of my left-wing friends but the other
thing that happened in the thirties was
something that Alexander field economic
historian is shown which is even though
the government was screwing it up in the
background innovation was continuing so
then when they kind of got out of this
threatening to move as so many countries
were to socialism or fascism in the 30s
they when we got over that kind of we've
had a girl
we had a great boom now that you've done
with this see this the first was
published in 2006 yeah second volume
2010 yeah third volume this year praise
the Lord
Laos Dale what are you working on now
well I'm working on a popular version of
the whole thing that I'm doing with art
Carden and art and I are gonna make a
kind of kind of a well we're kind of
thinking of airport type book because
these you know all those these are
wonderful books and
there they're not exactly summer reading
I I have to admit you know you could try
it but I think you'd like me the whole
summer to read it put it by her I have
short chapters I learned that a long
time ago short chapter is the way to go
so you can put it by your bed and like
the Bible you can read a chapter and
fall asleep so we're going to do that
and then I've got a longer term project
than you you and I are involved in which
is to revise a
microeconomics book of mine discovers a
long time ago because I really want to
get economists understanding simple what
we call price theory I've got a style
book called economical writing which the
University of Chicago is gonna bring out
as a as a third edition it's a little
short thing and then kind of after that
I'm thinking of a book called God in
Mammon economic sermons and I'm Anna has
you said at the beginning I'm an I'm an
Episcopalian I I know it's shameful but
there you are
and I want my progressive Episcopalian
friends to to to to realize that that
capitalism is not necessarily corrupting
of the soul so these will be actual
sermons a short book which will show
that
Jesus wasn't an socialist we're now
gonna turn it to you the audience for
questions to direct it at Deirdre Allah
run the queue here but if anyone has any
questions for Deirdre about our
discussion or about anything that you've
read her D etre say and more generally
now if your opportunity yeah mark well
why'd you stand up when you do it so so
the microphone I can hear you sure so I
want to know recently with Donald
Trump's election there's been a lot of
discussion about putting them in
Murray's hypothesis about the increasing
class divide in the u.s. between the
upper-middle class educated elite and
sort of the general population and I was
wondering given your focus on ideas it
seems that there are some similarities
between how they approach the problem
and that certain values are transmitted
in the upper class and the lower class
does not have those values and is
partially a reason for their economic
maybe not decline but they're not
economic their lack of economic success
has the same level as the PERT well that
particular argument is older than then
Putnam armory a Bob Fogle my friend and
colleague wrote a book about fifteen
years ago called the fourth grade
enlightenment which which made exactly
that argument he said that what the
problem in the United States is he was
focusing on it it's not poverty of a
material character that's not what the
problem is
the the problem is well spiritual
poverty so to speak bob was rather
explicit about it it might be good to
know that bob was a paid organizer for
the Communist Party and was married to a
black
woman for for all his life his adult
life way before it was a tall
fashionable to be a bi-racial couple so
so it's an older argument it's plausible
to me that that you can have cultural
values that [ __ ] you
without them you know the people say oh
it's blaming the victim it's not blaming
the victim it's just hoping the victim
will see look I was for a while at the
University of California Riverside
they're on a fellowship for it and I
kept being told by administrators there
that the large Hispanic population in
Southern California working-class often
didn't think of college and would be
tempted by their uncle's offer to join
their lawn mowing firm instead of going
to college they said this was a constant
problem he's bright Hispanic kids
wouldn't apply to college so you know I
worry about that on the other hand I
worry more about the rather obvious
impositions on poor people in the United
States that that come from the
government I'm from the government and
I'm here to help you and and like the
war on drugs we would have much more
prosperous and Hispanic and
african-american neighborhoods if we
didn't had never had a war on drugs
question
thank you for we're talking thank you
for talking to us about your book at
some point during during the
conversation you use the recent examples
of India and China
to support your thesis those wondering
so if indeed
what matters is these ideas at the
granular granular level yeah how is it
that a that it change happens it's such
a short within such short periods of
time that you know one changing policy
brings about well it's you know it's the
Indian case that I know the best because
I had a student who worked in a
dissertation about it
his name is odd yeah and he showed that
it did come from the bottom or actually
I don't think it was the bottom look
here's the central planners and the top
intellectuals and the government
officials up here here are the people
and what I think matters most is not
what comes from the people by itself or
the government but what goes on in
between the conversation of the society
the talk of the society the ethical
discussion but he noticed that in
Bollywood movies in the after
independence in the in the 50s and 60s
the heroes were government bureaucrats
and the enemies were people in business
and then it started to change
maybe there's simply material cause of
this they finally realized that these
government officials you know weren't
weren't their friends and it just it
switched around until by the by the 70s
late 70s and 80s Indian popular culture
was sneering at the police and the
planners and the regulator's not at the
the people in enterprise so I that's one
example but but I think you're right
here's a point that I make in the book
very frequently ideas can change very
quickly
we took some people say oh I see what
you're saying Durga
you're saying the culture matters no not
quite saying that I'm saying that
rhetoric matters that how people talk
matters and that can change quickly very
fast in a society it doesn't always but
it can we should call the habits of the
lip the habits of the lip eros
I'd like you to ponder on the
relationship between interest and ideas
yeah try to understand how ideas can
change in a hostile environment I'm
wondering how this is possible if the
incentive structure and the power
structure is hostile to those ideas now
mentioning I'll be mentioning Africa for
instance which is a case you do very
very optimistic about yeah how can we
bring about the change of ideas and
bring the ideas for joy equality it's
such a hostile institutional and power
structure yeah well that's the big
historical question or the big
historical fact where the point that
that for millennia in agricultural
societies the power structure was
hostile to new ideas about the economy I
mean it's very noticeable that economics
is like geology is invented in the 18th
century by Scots people and you can say
the French and we're involved and so
forth but it's mainly a Scottish
invention and why why did that happen
why did this system of liberalism that
we call economics at least until 1848
develop rather suddenly in a little
corner of North Western Europe and so
the the ideas can change but you're
right if the if the powers-that-be work
on it they can stop them as they
successfully did for seven
years in the Soviet Union
why they change is crucial I
because if well before the idea is to
have an effect they have to be new ideas
and where you get new ideas depends
sometimes it's internal to the logic of
the idea
I'd say the idea of equality as I've
defined it is a shockingly novel idea
that has a tendency to get bigger and
bigger and bigger to apply to more and
more people women in the United States
and Britain our big forces in the
anti-slavery movement immense the in the
early 19th century and then they say to
themselves and to other people men
they're called say how about us and out
of that came the women's movement and
then and then and then gay people in the
60s that great wonderful time and
honestly it was started to say wait a
minute and the drag queens fought the
cops and in in New York so so the ideas
didn't I I think there's internal logic
to ideas that makes them expand
sometimes but sometimes there's a
journal object that makes them collapse
I don't know but but it's not just
sociological forces although in the case
of Europe in the 16th and 17th century
it's it's these accidents I talked about
before I call on PETA I'll point out
that we're taping this one day after the
US Treasury announced that Harriet
Tubman the PS I'm delighted by that
which is it's an inspired choice
I'm simply appalled that Jackson was on
it for so long I said oh we're gonna
change the $10 bill for God's sakes stop
it
go after Jackson this racist it's not
just
acts that he owned but he is very sweet
treatment of Native Americans is
something to remember be yeah I have two
questions the first one is a fraud one
I've been listening on the pavement
because probably because I don't have
the patience to read it the Ambrose book
on the Lewis and Clark expedition so on
thought that courage
so that's 1803 and yeah one of the
things that just struck me so I'm it's
an I'm kind of in the beginning of the
book there in st. Louis they're camping
down for the winter yeah and they're
having a conversation and then in the
Diaries they just got discuss meeting
someone I can't remember the name right
now but they said he's more Adam Smith
than Adam Smith's book oh really
and making fun of them oh yeah and
that's by 1803 so it's only like in a
short period of time so there's
something about ideas and then the the
clarity that was already kind of
smearing a sneering in a way that you
know and so it's kind of this reminds me
backs
by the way of a Bob Higgs when I was a
graduate student I went and saw a
lecture by Bob Higgs yeah and he told
the story about Jonathan use yeah great
teacher and and you said that Jonathan
you said Bob if you think that you know
the government's growing you should have
seen what the Colonials those guys
wanted to interfere all the time and
everyone there's nothing new about
trying to interfere ensnare your capital
it's true so I'm going to ask you a
little bit about when can ideas
sustained sneering and when can the
sneering become so great that ideas
can't survive and because by saying I
don't know but we've got to take ideas
seriously that's all it's it would be
very strange to give a history of the
United States that didn't take seriously
all men are created equal the goon the
the Gettysburg Address
I have a dream come on words matter and
ideas matter but how one part of the
intellectual world that deals with this
again I say is the humanities and my
colleagues and friends in English and
history and and so forth are students of
these matters and they can tell you how
the idea of equality for African
Americans developed and to some degree
to why it developed or was obstructed so
I this issue of sneering because think
about post communist Russia
yeah you know and that sort of sort of
popular characterizations that people
have about things do people have to in
fact become non sneers in order to be
able to have the bushwa society and
going back to your point I mean it's
this Don racist I think one way to
interpret your ideas is that there's
ideas there's institutions and there's
practices and that without the spark of
the ideas the institutions and practices
don't actually go in the right way so
you're not saying that capital
accumulation doesn't matter but if you
don't have the idea of a brick building
you're them not going to be able to
build a brick building and and but it
would be crazy to say that it's the
bricks that caused the building to be
built it's the idea that caused it
so I want to just ask you this question
this is what I was yeah so you got in a
car you got picked up at Dulles you see
all this wealth one of the things that's
happened over the last 25 years is that
Washington DC has become the hub of a
lot of the richest counties in America
you know and it wasn't because of
creation of any kind of well don't
come here I noticed yeah and so on the
one hand you have an expansion with you
like you said that there's this you know
renewed idea that we can't stop this
this wealth creation or whatever wealth
consumption or whatever but there's a
line in Adam Smith that I wanted to ask
you about so The Wealth of Nations Smith
says the natural effort of every
individual to better his own condition
is so powerful that it is alone and
without any assistance not only capable
of carrying on the society to wealth and
prosperity but of surmounting a hundred
impertinence truck shion's what's the
folly of human laws too often encumbers
its operations and so I'm wondering when
we look around we have two things going
on which is on the one hand we have this
rent-seeking state which is the folly of
human laws but I'm giving and we have
all these you know ways to get around
the obstruction right and I'm wondering
if there's how the role and ideas play
in us being able to tip that balance in
one way or the other
well a let's take an electic a local
example the the public choice approach
to thinking about the role of the
government so-called public choice and
also the Virginia school you can call it
lots of things and if we can get across
the idea that that the government is not
composed of Swedish philosopher Kings
will have accomplished a great deal I
have cousins who worked for the CIA and
so I you know I'm and they're very nice
people but every time I come to
Washington I'm appalled that all these
intelligent people like my cousin are
working for the Great Beast here's
here's a fact that I calculated in the
book the third book take out of the
hundred and seventy ranked countries for
honesty of public administration you
know they have these rankings all the
time that they're about a hundred and
seventy countries
let's take the top 30 Spain as if
emerging and call those honest countries
and for those countries Sweden Minnesota
New Zealand you might think it's not
completely insane to give the government
more money in power now actually I don't
think so but let's be generous to our
Social Democratic friends so so yes
someone famously said giving more money
to the government it's like giving
giving whiskey to a teenage boy but
let's let's pretend that that if you're
these wonderfully honest Swedish
bureaucrats that'll be okay then ask
what percentage of the world's
population is governed by these top 30
and it's not a very great spent high
standard the top 30 and it's 14% so 86%
of the world is governed by governments
that everyone agrees our hopelessly
corrupt and you wouldn't want to give
any more money the Italian government
for example every Italian knows this
Italy is ranked 75th in this ranking
that's it's equal to Vietnam and the
kersek Republic that's my beloved Italy
I mean I love Italy but anyone I have
Italian friends who are kind of hopeless
Social Democrats and I don't get it they
know that giving more money to this
government it's a terrible terrible idea
and yet it goes on we have time for one
more quick question there was someone
back here who yeah I think as a GM you
alumni one of the most shocking things
about especially your second book was
downgrading the status of trade
and talking about it's just it's just
moving stuff around yeah it doesn't
really help and I'm sort of I don't know
if this is the right venue I guess but
I'm very curious about this idea of it
really is the local the nature of local
production that matters you know sort of
the story that I get out of standard
economics or a standard libertarian fair
would be free trade had something to do
with the Industrial Revolution the
reason for the Irish potato famine was
the British restricted trade that the
Irish were allowed to do but in your
book you specifically say it was
straightforward Malthusian carrying
capacity so I don't know if well you
know trade is extremely important
context and free trade but but you know
I I ought to label this concern that I
have in the second book I should have
called it the Herberger problem after my
old colleague el harberger you pointed
this out over and over again the
efficiency effects of trade are fine and
that I just bought last year I bought an
accordion a lady is someone who knows
how to play an accordion but doesn't and
I couldn't have built the accordion
myself and it came from Czechoslovakia
and I was delighted to have it it's a
wonderful little instrument so so trade
is good and it makes us much better off
and if you cut off trade entirely we'd
all be going back to $1 a day or worse
but the really big effective trade I
think is done is as we say in this kind
of weasel word is dynamic it's more
about innovation it's more about forcing
Indians to stop not innovating about
breakfast cereal
by preventing Kellogg from importing
into India as they did for for many many
years
the American automobiles we're not very
good until we dropped quotas and tariffs
on automobiles and suddenly GM had to
compete with Toyota and Volvo so you
know not against trade I'm just saying
that that the conventional static belief
that oh yeah you just or the idea that a
lot of people have that the trade is
somehow income itself this is a point
I've been making since I was very young
that trade is good but it's not the same
thing as income it's not it's not
identical it's what what you need is new
ideas new configurations and having more
context aisles exported from Great
Britain is not what made the British
rich what made the Brammer what made
them rich is widespread ingenuity I'm
Jay as I said I'm just reading a book a
biography of frigate nonsan it's very
noticeable than in his travels around
the Arctic in Russia the people who he
has to rely on are German and English
and Scottish by origin because the
Russians are unreliable they won't keep
their commercial promises so you can't
buy dogs from them sled dogs so trade is
important but the the underlying ethic
of saying things like oh you made a
fortune inventing a new steam engine
that's wonderful you go to it let's have
some more of that that's really what
made the modern world
well thank you Deirdre it's been fun I
can enlightening and I encourage I'm
sure you won't disagree with this idea
I encourage everyone to buy several
copies and read and study and this is a
remarkably important and insightful
piece of scholarship thank you dear
thanks
[Applause]
inside the Hayek suite you're all
invited please join us